today's video is sponsored by Sanford
Shepherd is a monthly subscription
service that gives you 600 different
brands that you can sample from from
different fragrances and cosmetics and
skincare products separate let you
choose a designer fragrance every month
for just $15 a month check it out it
comes in these little velvet bags mm-hmm
and it comes in these sticks and I
personally use this especially when I
travel because before I had one of these
twisty cases I would buy the South Pole
travel size right and then when the
problem with that is when you throw it
in your hygiene bag or your luggage
everything gets squish and it sprays and
it contaminates like your whole luggage
and everything smells and it gives you a
headache
it has this little safe little container
that when you go like this now it's nice
and safe like a lipstick or chapstick it
will never come out and also what I like
about it is its travel safe
so all of them are under 4 ounces so you
won't get stopped by TSA or customs or
whatever and every single month II can
send you a different designer fragrance
so that you could test all them cuz if
you go to the mall you have to buy a big
ol bottle and then you smell it
awesome all is good at the mall then
when you go home or like what the hell I
don't like it anymore you're just left
with the big old bottle and each bottle
gives you a 120 to 140 sprays that's a
lot and look they fill it up all the way
to the top you see that yep all kinds of
brands like product gucci tom ford and a
bunch of indie brands
this one's kenneth cole blackballed i
like this one this one's Gucci Guilty
poor home guilty poor the homies yeah
smells smells I get plus now they have
products from other categories like
skincare wellness and makeup and make
sure you use coupon code gen 30 to get
30% off your first month at scent bird
comm it's just $10 for your first month
that's right $10 for your first month or
just go ahead and click in the
description box below there's gonna be a
little link that takes you straight to
the senton bird and you're gonna get our
deal oh I like this one this one is
costume nationals sent in tips and out
of their selection there is plenty of
designer fragrances for men
women how do you pronounce this but
above all Gauri Bvlgari why is that a V
and not a you've being fancy so out of
these I think I'm more drawn to this one
it's the Gucci Guilty one and that's
because it smells like you just came out
of shower so I'm a big fan of very fresh
citrusy smelling fragrances and this one
is it this one is Kenneth Cole
black bald mmm I like this one because
it smells like you're on your first day
after you just broke up from a
relationship in not a dog news
it's a submitted by Canadian Z they
really do say that yeah yeah hey yeah
yeah I was really listening for it too
yeah they say alright yeah I do found it
delightful it's great I love Canadian in
Canada they just call it dry not an
encounter dry make the distinction a man
accidentally hit what he thought was a
dog but discovered it was a wild animal
oh she's like a wild dog who's gonna be
like it was a grandma crawling around on
the freeway it was a grandma on a dog
costume yeah Oh probably a coyote or
something a no possum Oh possum oh wow
those are not wild are they we've only
seen domesticated
I've never seen a domestic actually saw
a PETA thing on Twitter they're like if
you're fine like a dead possum you
should cut it open and open up the
stomach to see if there's Babies in
there what that's what people to let
them out and give them a chance I'm
sorry you think I'm gonna see a possum
also sometimes that possum is so flat
and who carries around surgical night
running just for this moment one [ __ ]
vet surgeon that's just like now's my
time he's harvesting the organs of
fossils anyway so alright so this story
here it takes place in Canadia and so
this man named Eli he was driving to his
night shift on a narrow rural road and
so he ended up clipping an animal who
flew into the ditch on the shoulder so
he parked and he used a flashlight to
look for it so he found this animal and
he says he thought it was a German
Shepherd or a husky I hit a dog he
didn't want to leave it lying on the
side of the road so he ended up picking
him up and laying it on the floor of his
Hyundai and so he
mile or so for his 10:00 p.m. shifts
[ __ ] resurrected and beat him in the
neck no you say that like this animal is
surprisingly very docile
I got no energy to [ __ ] growl at you
right now dude I'm gonna die so then
once you got to his internally bleeding
a co-worker went out to look at the
animal and that's when the co-worker who
let him know it was actually a coyote oh
yeah it's a werewolf man you know what's
crazy
I saw eight of these [ __ ]
yesterday eight yeah yes I live right
next to like the hills and then so Geo
she was looking through our nest and she
was like there's coyotes outside and so
she sent me a screenshot and I'm like
why near your house yeah right outside
of my ocean of pictures right after I
went outside of my door and there was
four of them right next to my truck and
another four right across the street
they were ganged up yeah there's a whole
pack of them okay gang bar woulda or the
[ __ ] star shooting this is for brown
[ __ ] [ __ ] eat my dog
wait me some right where there's a whole
pound of him yeah
my dog I even buy a [ __ ] bunch of
coyotes yeah my god really
yeah cuz a couple of my dogs got loose
when I was out on vacation and then they
were out in the hills and then there's a
there was a graveyard near that area and
a [ __ ] ton of coyotes there oh snap
yeah they got into a fight they found
yeah you got to turn into Hawkeye man no
dude I was like he's just coyote hunter
no coyote ugly that's too many coyotes
anyway only population control
if they happen to my kitties you're on
vigilante killing every [ __ ] I'll even
go to like areas that's unrelated like
I'm gonna go outside of California
Arizona I'll just be on a coyote killing
spree
coyotes yeah Jamie's the one who killed
Brown yeah none of them can ever have to
you always and then you find the coyote
is facing the other direction he's like
imma get it before I could [ __ ] up that
guy he's like right-hand man pops out
he's like I got this one boss come on
son Jon we kind of beaten for the
different your county was in a village
[Laughter]
that's always what blows my mind about
most TV staging is how that whole thing
work somebody turns around and they're
talking to the person still listening to
them it's normal like if you do that to
me the fact that he waits and they have
a conversation and he throws the gun
down it's like maybe you've been waiting
to kill this dude why what are you doing
it's so confusing it'd be weird to watch
that can you imagine watching two people
in a room and if you have a conversation
and then somebody walks away from the
other person
and just looked at the wall while
they're still talking are you okay yeah
yeah yeah we're supposed to fight right
now yeah you good like need a moment
like you need a warm-up like I'm warmed
up I just fought through your entire
company here so then that's when you
like discovered that it was a coyote
because of the [ __ ] them coyotes mm-hmm
but they were saying that this was this
is a really small coyote who's only
about 30 pounds is a small I still kill
them it's still a coyote to me from
Canada and you have no [ __ ] relation
that your whole set that I'm after
[Music]
I'm gonna be like a genocide all
dictator for that whole species
mmm-hmm coyotes yep of coyotes it wasn't
even a coyote Joe and they've the real
animal framed the coyote cuz he knew you
would react this way a turtle kill did
not kill the coyote it's all dramatic
it's like cuts to like turtles
one day it's never the animal you really
suspect not quite what you were
expecting
[Laughter]
[Laughter]
and then you also trained to kill
coyotes you didn't Rena quarterly you
kind of the reasons why we have to
switch to paper straws you know they are
the actual villain listen [ __ ] see how I
got Jordan he turtles in this video this
isn't I know I know the planet and the
earth and all that I get it but paper
straws where I draw the line
meet you brother Mike matters we maybe
will know me to have earth forever
I need plastic straws it's wet are made
out of like the sugar stuff do you eat
it after you're done no oh I didn't try
eating it I don't know what why can't we
replace all straws with 7-eleven sour
straws valid question those work pretty
good and all those cereal straws oh yeah
no they made drinking up for your milk
of with like cereal and stuff like that
so I like the ball inside the bowl thing
doing it in the bowl make sense but just
slurping it is weird
I thought you said you were raised like
a trash person just get this invited
yeah but I did not like drinking out of
them so I still am trash enough to own
it
got it yeah but anyway back to this kod
ended up like he didn't he didn't [ __ ]
or pee a little hunter coyote by the way
third time no joke so you know saying
that there were 11 hours that this
coyote lives in the backseat cuz he had
to wait for a wildlife people to show up
and eventually they did and then they
took him in and then said that the
coyote was between one and three years
old and that it had suffered some like
scratches and like you didn't hit him
hard enough
like he got head trauma with the
collision mannequin he's out six to
eight weeks that's all you're so chill
face and legs exactly that's what they
were saying or like that's that's the
reason why I was awesome but yes that
was it it was just he thought it was a
dog he he carried it to his car it looks
straight up like a coyote though it's
not either like oh you could kind of be
a husky
no it's straight up maybe at nighttime
there's no mixing it just looks like a
wild animal
it does not look like I would say coyote
Fox or it I'll say [ __ ] coyote baby
wolf before I say action dog that she
looks like it hunts armadillo and [ __ ]
my dogs we try to get it to say it like
oh [ __ ] he's not City surprise the guy
could drive it or maybe [ __ ] dogs are
tough Rebecca is day you know he's like
coyotes or dogs to like that kind of
personnel
[Music]